Okay, we are back.
I was thinking of just calling it a day
early, but then I realized
this is not going to get done until I do
it. So, let's get doing it. [sighs]
So I think that this was uh we figured
out that entropy was the likely
thing wrong which is weird because
entropy is like the simplest bloody
piece of this.
Go figure it out. So we have the forge
kernel and the forge kernel
computes the loss
and there's the entropy is right there.
Okay.
So then
I was supposed to block off the other
gradients
Okay.
zero logits for this. Cool.
Let's see if this does anything.
And if not, then we get confused.
The entropy is supposed to be the really
easy kelp.
And no
cool.
Let me try one other thing just to be
sure that I did this correctly.
Make sure it's not doing the value grad
somehow.
Okay, it's not. So somehow
uh it seems like somehow our
entropy grad which is supposed to be the
simple one is wrong.
Okay,
but it's right in the forward path. So
then the gradient of the entropy is
somehow wrong.
Go look.
Make sure that we didn't mess this up.
It doesn't look like I messed with
anything, right?
And then it's just straight up
elites.
Make sure we didn't mess with anything
other than the grads.
Grab values
at logits.
And we'll just make sure that this is
exactly what I think it is.
I don't think it is.
It's possible.
Stupid thing needs to compile faster
though.
The deal I'm going to make myself here
is that if I get the all four colonels,
this is the last colonel. So, if I get
this working and training works, I'm
done for the night.
That's the deal.
Oh, what's this?
That's just a comment.
And now we still now we are at one E
minus 6
which is still off
like substantially.
Now we can start. Okay. Well, first of
all, this is an XF.
didn't change it.
Okay.
Uh let's go look for entropy.
That's the only thing I can see.
Entropy should match very very closely.
Yeah. Yeah. There's so many of these
little ones that I just must have
missed.
there.
All right. Well, I mean, it's the thing
with 186 is 1 E6 can just be float
screwing with you.
I have to actually make sure we're using
double functions for everything.
Like, obviously, I don't want to ship
this in double precision, right? But
like we're debugging it.
and one minus 8.
They're still not perfect.
Let's see how I'm computing this
normally.
So I just do
um
negative p log p dot sum do mean
all right let's try some other stuff
here.
new log P.
Let's just set um
like this.
There's new log P
Is it the sum?
manide
by
n * t.
Okay.
why is that 2048 by 64?
Oh, no. That's correct.
But then
isn't it just return like this?
Am I wrong?
Ah,
there we go.
De mean difference?
I don't think so.
Guess we'll see.
is
if P log P.
I set this to thread loss.
Wait,
Rob's new
Yeah. So this is actually the very close
one.
What is it? Log prob.
The correct entropy formulation.
This how I do it.
and I might have done it wrong in here.
So, it has logit and actions.
Wait, what?
Entropy of normalized logits.
It's logit minus logit log some x
Okay, let me just make absolutely
freaking
sure.
Let me just make absolutely freaking
sure before I go drive myself insane
doing this.
gradient has
values.
Still not right though.
So it's screwed either way.
Got to be kidding me.
Okay, the value loss is correct.
That is like completely freaking
correct.
Okay,
now we can ignore this.
Go off.
Take out
rad of the value.
Okay.
Take out
this one.
FBR.
I'm trying to fix it.
Driving me insane.
B log soft max
then X.
But then it says my backward pass is
very slightly off.
No, it's at this point I'm tired and I
want this to be solved, man.
X
L minus log some X right
log some X
ah
you see
We have the 1 e minus 8 here
in the log sum Next.
I don't think we have that in uh in our
version.
How do we now have um how do we now have
it slightly off?
Okay, it's nondeterministic. Lovely.
Okay, let's take the the real one though
is
this
Start with this.
Okay.
You could have also looked up any of the
number of like very well-ritten articles
on the topic.
Okay. Yeah. So, it's definitely this
one. The policy gradient loss is like
way the hell off, right?
Way the hell off.
And now I guess we can I
There are blog posts that will do that
for you.
It's not called annotated transformer.
It's just one of the one of the random
posts I happen to know of on this of the
very many posts on this.
Like you picked a topic that probably
has the most well-written content about
it in ML.
And then instead of using it, you
decided to get a [ __ ] [ __ ] language
model that lies to you half the time.
I don't know, man. It's a pet peeve of
mine.
It's like when I get multiple people on
the stream saying, "Hey, I put puffer
lib into a language model and it told me
like I should use the puffer, you know,
the puffer puff class or whatever." It's
like, why the [ __ ] do you ask the
language model? I put time into making
these docks, not [ __ ]
Then use the LLM to point you to
resources that don't suck.
Like use it as a search engine. Don't
use it like don't use it to try to
replace the materials themselves. It's
just going to give you a worse summary.
It's like there are relatively small
number of very high quality resources
out there that you should use.
Okay. Interesting.
So,
guess we do this then, huh?
one.
this wrong.
Getting tired.
Push a little bit more though tonight.
Yes. Okay. Now we just very very
carefully add some stuff back
We're going to do this painstakingly
cuz I don't
I basically don't have any brain cells
done for the night. Uh I don't have any
brain cells left for the night. So,
we're just going to do this like
painstakingly.
I don't even have to think about it.
interesting work.
Yeah. So, this is um hyperf kernels for
uh puffer lib 4.
We're going to try to get 10 million
step per second RL.
Um, and right now I'm just fighting
numerical issues, like very small bugs
with gradients. So, this is a pretty
large bug. For some reason, I'm just not
doing clipping backwards.
I'm too tired to do this manually. So,
let me just do
this. Is simple enough that even a dumb
language model shouldn't screw this up,
I would imagine.
Yeah, it just wasn't doing the clipped
loss.
So, it was calculating clipped loss but
doing unclipped grabs.
There we go. Now we actually have
correct grads.
Now I can do
Let's see if we are lucky enough that
this whole thing just works.
Too freaking long with the compile time.
I probably should like bother to fix
that.
Um
I don't know. I This whole setup is just
really annoying to me because like I'm
somewhat out of my element here. If I
were building an environment for
instance, I would have instant compile
times.
But because I have to deal with torch
and everything
here.
This
Of course, we still have the entropy
gradient being a little stupid.
Okay, E minus 12 on the clipped
loss is really nice.
Um,
let's do the entropy grad now.
Six.
The full loss.
that
and we have to enable this.
There's my value gradient.
There we go.
If I were just working in CUDA without
the PyTorch mess bound to it and slowing
everything down, it would be chill.
Part of your PhD.
I uh I finished my PhD about a year and
a half ago. A little more at this point.
This library is now the fastest
performing and the fastest growing
library in reinforcement learning. I
work on this full-time.
Uh this is when I started working on it
full-time right here.
And we're now training at several
million steps per second. And uh that's
in the Python back end. And now in
Puffer 4, I'm working on adding a C++
backend with a bunch of custom kernels
that should get us to 10 million steps
per second training. Whole bunch of
other new things coming soon as well.
All open source.
All here on puffer.ai. Star the repo. It
helps the puff feed the puffer.
You like stars.
Why you are stuck with torch?
Because I'm trying to write non-trivial
networks.
So if I don't have a torch bind, nobody
will use the library. Uh, if I try to do
all CUDA from scratch all at once, it's
not going to freaking work because I'm
trying to implement more than just like
a two-layer MLP.
So, the only thing I really can do is I
can just incrementally like eat away at
torch and fuse a whole bunch of
operations into custom kernels and then
kind of just like get performance back
bit by bit and then still have the torch
bindings. You know, it's technically
possible I could do this whole thing
just with custom ops that are just bound
to the torch front end.
Very nice. Thank you.
Yeah, this is something of a crusade
here to like make RL fast and sane and
broadly accessible and useful across a
number of areas of science.
Magnumopus, if you will.
Oh, this is already training with the PO
loss. It's stable. Cool.
So, the entropy grad could be a little
bit smoother.
Um, but this actually works.
That's kind of awesome.
Autonomous marine vehicle. That's cool.
You're going to train a a puffer bot
with the puffer.
Check my guides on X. If you click my
articles tab, all my best advice is in
there. Opinionated RL guide and then my
programming and ML guide.
Well, I definitely want to save this now
before I break anything.
I'm a little too tired to be inspiring
at the moment, mind you. I kind of just
been grinding this.
Were you around earlier for the morning
run story?
I froze myself half to death this
morning
trying to uh trying to run. I forgot the
weather forecast. I thought it was like
50 outside, so I was like, "Wow, I'm
really cold. That's weird. I can't feel
my hands." Yeah. Apparently, I went um
apparently I went running in like, you
know, mid to high30s
uh with like crazy windchill in a
t-shirt and shorts.
[laughter]
That's why I'm still all wrapped up. I'm
like freaking still cold from this
morning somehow.
is on the radar considering been some
interesting things and being applied to
what I'm currently looking into.
Awesome.
Yeah, I mean if you check out the stuff
that I have the content around this,
it's actually surprisingly easy to get
into a lot of it now. It used to not be
the case at all. It used to be just like
the hardest thing ever. Now it's pretty
good.
Now it's pretty good.
Go check entropy again.
What time is it?
It's not even 8 yet, right?
Yeah. So, I can work a little bit more
on this.
if the user cannot set a custom torch
model, nobody will use my library. Like,
you literally can't do RL that way
because you can't have a
one-sizefits-all torch model.
I also am not generally a fan of like
abstracting [ __ ] from the user. I like
to make things low-level and clean.
Boy, I'm in Turkey writing CN C++.
It's good. You should be build some cool
environments, build some cool projects,
learn some stuff.
Oh, yeah. I also I have to merge some I
have some PRs open on this, but if
you're looking for something dumb and
fun to do, I made this site onlyfish.ai,
AI where you can submit puffers to this
site and I can merge them in. So you
basically you can train a puffer and try
to get a puffer that behaves differently
from the other puffers and then you can
feed them stars.
I kind of hacked this environment of
ours and then I made it like interactive
and stuff.
It's only fish.
[laughter]
That was for um hitting 20k followers.
That was like the special event.
I was going to make it Only Fins, but uh
Only Fins, the domain was taken for a
Finnish dating site.
I'm not even making that up.
That sounds like super made up. You can
look it up. It's like an under
construction finished dating site.
[snorts]
Then don't. Honestly, I hate C++. You
don't need C++, man. Just write M's in
C. All our M's are in C. The only reason
I'm doing any C++ now is because I have
to for the torch bindings. You're going
to see that by the time I have this
thing built for um for like puffer 4,
it's going to be as close to sea style
everywhere as I can possibly manage.
Okay. So, this is probably just our log
soft max.
very difficult to advance
years while studying.
What do you need to do to apply and be
accepted?
so to be honest with you, basically
anything that you're able to do like at
any reasonable level, you're going to be
compensated way way way better in the US
than in Turkey. So pretty much if you
get anything reasonable here from like a
legitimate company that's not just
trying to like uh farm visa workers
under bad conditions, well probably
you'll be doing well off immed like
immediately.
Um
and then from there it's mostly about
like what are you actually passionate
enough about to become uh near the top
of the field, right?
There's pretty much no upper ceiling in
the US.
It's just about how good you can get and
of course what you can do with it.
So if you are um if you work hard and
you're ambitious,
I always recommend people try to come to
the US because it's the country for it.
Is that how you're able to work on
Puffer full-time?
Uh, well, I'm a US citizen. I'm American
born and raised. Um, and no, I so with
Puffer,
all my stuff is open source, but we
build like custom high performance
simulations with uh for companies. We do
like dedicated R&D support. So we do
have a few things that we offer. I mean
Puffer is a relatively new company. I've
been doing this less than two years and
already we've made the whole pretty much
all of Rell like 100 to a thousand times
faster depending on the project.
So right now we have a couple companies
that we do stuff with. Uh we're growing
that but we're not like trying to grow
it super quickly, right? you know, I'm
mostly focused on the research and then
when companies come to us like, "Hey,
can you do this type of a sim, we price
it and we have a few contracts like that
and that side will grow a lot more in
the future, but for the time being, I'm
really focused on uh on research and
it's mainly like, you know, I'm not
really advertising it a ton outside of
just having um you know the stuff that I
do on X
and then the companies that are excited
about this stuff they find us anyways
pretty much it
be visa issues on both Turkish and US.
What? They don't let you leave
the projects. Oh yeah, absolutely. Then
if it helps you, by all means build cool
stuff and submit to Puffer. They're very
happy to see that.
And Puffer has, as open source goes,
it's
very legit project.
What's going on here?
Uh, we had this thing working.
Yeah, you'd like RL to be off the shelf,
but it's not offtheshelf tech, man.
This is like actually hard.
It's more off the shelf than it used to
be,
And we do have like we have a default
policy that'll work for like a lot of M
that we like we use, but like it like
your end would have to have flat state
data basically. So custom encoders are
still very much a thing.
Okay. I'm really not loving the numeric
here.
Yeah, it does train, but the numeric are
not amazing.
Yeah. All right. So, the entropy is
still a little janky.
Um, I think I'm going to call it a
night, though.
Like we've gotten it to be in a pretty
good spot.
We have like one more thing maybe to fix
on the numeric.
They're pretty damn close to uh to
torch.
And I need some rest. So,
thank you for tuning in, folks.
Um,
all my work's free and open source if
you'd like to check it out. Puffer.ai.
Star the repo to feed the puffer.
Discord if you want to get involved and
X for educational materials, research,
and the like. Good night.
Integrate Puffin Autonomous Marine RL.
That looks